[Music]
what's up mkbhd here and i today now
have a new favorite two-door electric
vehicle
and when i say that out loud it you
probably picture one thing
this is very different
so i've been talking about these
electric vehicle prototypes for a bit
you know how i've been saying they're
easy to build you can make one because
it's true we see car companies all the
time just build one single car with a
custom chassis on some electric motors
and a battery and boom they prayed that
around but the hard part is building and
shipping them in mass but all that being
said this is easily one of the coolest
electric car builds i've ever seen so
it's made by ford and this is actually a
concept car so they don't even have
plans to ship it but after seeing all
the reactions to this and driving it
around for myself for a day i think it
would be amazing if they reconsidered it
but either way let me show you around
this thing so basically what you're
looking at right now is a 1978 ford
f-100 illuminator but under the hood
is the guts of a 2022 ford mustang machi
gt that's the performance edition
it is a wild juxtaposition of brand new
2022 things alongside the 40 year old
solid metal and glass things of this
older truck i swear if this was a doug
demiro video there'd be endless quirks
and features but yeah the final result
here is an electric truck that not only
looks like really nothing else on the
road but it actually drives basically
the same as the performance edition
machi which is one of the faster ones
out there 480 horsepower over 600
pound-feet of torque yes you can break
hold launch yes it does zero to 60 in
3.5 seconds
and yeah it does feel and look and sound
ridiculous while doing it
now i don't know about you but i don't
get a chance to look at trucks from 1978
very often so sorry if this is like
super unsurprising but pretty much
everything about the outside of this
truck is either an awesome shape or
custom rebuilt as new so it's got the
style and the lines of the times it's
got the silver and copper paint colors
the old school wheels are also custom to
match and they also happen to hide the
bright red performance calipers of the
maki's brakes under there pretty well
and just poking around this thing it's
fun to see how much of the original body
is left untouched this six foot bed is
basically completely solid metal and the
tailgate's super heavy to open and close
because there's no mechanical assistance
like modern trucks even the doors when
you open them i don't know i just find
it fascinating that you can just look at
the mechanical method right in there for
holding the door open at two different
amounts probably the only way you would
know that this is a resto mod if you saw
it on the street would be if maybe you
noticed the camera cutouts there is one
in the back license plate here for the
reverse camera
and there's another one up at the front
in the grille cutout up here at which
point you realize the whole grill is
fake it's just a black plastic in there
like the rest of the mustang mockies
well either that or you happen to see it
plugged in and charging because that's a
giveaway that flap at the front left
bumper is in fact a normal ccs charging
port the inside though okay this is
where it goes crazy there is a healthy
combination of old and new and even some
new that's disguised as old to fit
better with the general aesthetic i
think it's super cool now obviously
there's no hiding the dashboard it's got
the mockee's huge vertical touchscreen
with the knob and everything and there's
also a display as the dash behind the
steering wheel so not the original dash
i think some people would have wanted
the original dash but there's so many
new systems and things going on here
like the fact that it's showing me 200
miles of range for example that i just
don't know how they could convert all
that stuff so all the software is in
here it's working the backup and forward
cameras are functional they also brought
in the headlight controls from the maki
but i did notice they're sideways so
maybe they didn't fit in the normal spot
and then the more you look around the
more you see parts cleverly disguised as
old the steering wheel for example it's
new but it says f-100 on it and it's got
the brown color and the seats are all
new but with the tan color to match the
rest of the interior which is completely
decidedly
old school so you get the plaid
stitching at the bottom of the door
little metal pieces everywhere like for
adjusting the side view mirrors the
glove compartment is just a metal box
like nothing fancy at all and the entire
ceiling too is stitched with leather and
the sun visors are just like metal wires
with leather pieces on them uh there's
also old-school speakers behind the
seats that are hooked up and seem to be
playing great quality audio which leads
me to believe they're also new disguised
as old
and you better believe this car has
manual rolling up windows there's no way
they could get rid of that it's
basically mandatory for a car of this
style so yeah a little bit old and a
little bit of new and this is the combo
you get it's just so funny seeing this
old whip rolling around through the
windshield but you can still see the top
half of a huge touch screen that's only
in new cars
it seems sacrilegious to have a center
console with wireless chargers right
next to
manual roll-up windows and door locks
put that's really what this is all about
it's adding the modern creature comforts
to a comfortable familiar old truck so i
did get to drive this thing around the
studio a bit for a day before ford went
and took it away to the i think they
brought it straight to the new york auto
show but i really got three main
questions from people that i showed this
to one
what's under the hood
interesting question
two how does it drive and three
can i get one
all good questions so first of all
literally under the hood is
mustang machi so this is a custom
chassis holding things together by a
company called roadster shop but yeah
basically all the electronics and hvac
and wiring things that are normally in
the front of a maki and hidden they're
all still here
plus basically that open bucket for
storage where the front trunk is so yeah
this thing still has a real front trunk
this 1978
restomod ford f-100 has a bigger front
trunk than most other electric cars on
the road right now
so okay how does it drive this is a
funny one so it's quite a character as
you can imagine
very livable and smooth and normal at
low speeds like around a neighborhood
this would actually be totally fun to
drive and maybe forgive me if this is
sacrilegious but i think i would prefer
to drive this over the 70s version
because you got the electric torque it's
smooth and silent no gear shifting
you've got regenerative braking one
pedal driving is great
but it's also a massively wide metal
truck that can lurch from 0 to 60 in 3.5
seconds and if you really pin it and
start playing with it like it has very
impressive acceleration but it's
obviously not going to handle great like
you can feel the dipping and swaying of
the chassis more than pretty much
anything else capable of going this fast
i didn't have it long enough to see how
well the range holds up but hey if it's
quoting me about 200 miles of range
that's not amazing but that's also not
terrible considering this thing has the
aerodynamics of a block of cheese so
after playing with it like i said people
were like where can i actually get one
of these and like i said it is a concept
car so this isn't an actual version that
you'll ever be able to buy but ford is
selling a crate motor that you can
actually use to convert other older cars
to electric so you don't have to build
everything by hand like zach is with his
hummer ev so and it's only four thousand
dollars it's 3 900 bucks for that which
was lower than i expected it to be so i
think that's the big takeaway of this
this concept truck which is so cool is
really just a proof of concept and i
think it's awesome i want to shout out
ford for making something so fun like
this definitely tag or send someone this
video who would want a retro modern
truck like this that's really what this
is the ultimate retro modern
truck
thanks for watching subscribe for more
and i'll see you guys in the next one
peace
[Music]